I've got 27 brand-new things you missed
from it that you haven't seen in any of
the other videos so stick around to the
end of this one where I'll reveal those
in the opening scene in Bill's room you
can see a pad and pencils on his bed a
nod to the fact that bill grows up to
become a writer in the book if you look
closer at the post where Patrick Hawke
stutters missing posters displayed
you'll notice that it's absolutely
covered in staples maybe not all of
those staples are from missing posters
for children but the number of staples
on that thing is pretty high and at the
end of the movie we see a similar number
of dead kids floating in Pennywise as
Leia so the staples really show us how
many missing children have been given up
on by the adults of daring what allows
this to happen is described as kind of a
trance over all the adults in derry most
of them seem to be in denial that
there's really a major problem with the
child abductions then as a newcomer to
the town noticed this in this research
haier disappeared six times the national
average couch is wearing an anthrax
shirt which is interesting because in
the book which is set in the 50s rather
than the 80s one of the few things that
all the kids seem to agree on lucky 7
and Bauer's gang alike is their love for
rock and roll a love that is not shared
with seemingly any of the adults in
derry that becomes kind of a motif a
symbolic representation of Penny wises
reign of terror and dairy adults are in
denial and kind of turn a blind eye to
the reality of the situation because
they're afraid of change whether it be
the rise of rock-and-roll in the 50s or
the rise of an evil being in their town
with this being said in the 80s maybe
metal serves that purpose now belch also
has an interesting shirt choice during
the rock fights during the rock fight
belch wears a t-shirt repping a demo CD
that Metallica put out in the 80s called
metal up your ass the graphic features a
hand holding a sword coming out of the
toilet perfect choice for a movie about
a dangerous clown creature who also
comes out of the sewers that's not the
only t-shirt in the movie that seemed to
be more than just a random choice though
there are actually many many more
starting with Eddie he can be seen
wearing this killer car shirt which is a
reference to Stephen King's novel
Christine about a vehicle that becomes
possessed and tries to kill its owner
bill wears a tracker bros t-shirt when
they go to investigate the sewers the
tracker British shipping company is a
family-owned trucking service from the
book they don't come up in the movie so
this is just a cool little easter egg
t-shirts were not the only thing in the
art department to have significance
let's roll that next clip bill has some
posters in his room and I was able to
identify a couple of them as gremlins
and Beetlejuice why is this significant
well I think these posters both have
double meanings behind them the first is
a foreshadowing of bills future you'll
find that after facing their fears in
the movie that none of the losers are
losers
anymore they all go on have very
successful careers perhaps the most
successful of them though is buildin
burrow who grows up to be a horror
writer like me but without the stupid
goatee
but it's cool to see that bill does have
an interest in horror as a kid and that
leads into his occupation as an adult
on a sidenote pretty much every Stephen
King novel has a protagonist who's a
writer a method he uses to project
himself into his work muschietti and his
art department could have chosen any two
horror movie posters to hang on bills
Waldo so why did they choose these I
mean outside of the fact that they're
both Warner Brothers movies and they
would never market for a competitor go
on me from a month ago for one bill
still a kid and these are both more
kid-friendly horror movies that came out
in the 1980s but I think there's a
reason that these were chosen as opposed
to say ghostbusters let's look at
gremlins it's a movie about these little
things that change into other more scary
things and in this movie its
shape-shifting abilities are on full
display one of which being the
transformation that it does with its
teeth when feeding off the fear of the
children it seemed like it took some big
inspiration from Barbara's
transformation in beetlejuice how the
face kind of peels back to reveal these
rows and rows of razor-sharp teeth
especially that scene where penny wise
is about to feed on Stan I was getting
major vibes from the Tim Burton classic
it seems that there was also some
inspiration from more traditional circus
clowns Georg's wallpaper and the overall
decor in his room from stuffed animals
to the little dolls on the nightstand
one of my favorite parts about the movie
is how there's always something looming
in the dark so in the next clip I'll
talk about what lies beyond
the whole basement scene is pretty dark
in the shot so let's turn up the lights
in the corner there are some ores and
there's also a life vest in the wall I
wonder if these choices have anything to
do with the fact that Georgie dies while
playing with the paper boat notes this
does make sense because this is right
before penny wise uses Georgie's image
to try to trick bill okay
this is creepy first thing I noticed is
penny 1 is sinking into the well if
fling goo didn't make wells creepy
enough for you it looks like the clown's
got you covered scattered on the floor
are children's clothes and toys this
looks kind of like an elephant another
circus animal and there's also a noose
hanging from the rafter this room is
full of various clowns and has a few
things that I loved I'll turn up the
lights again to make it easier for you
to see this little guy right here is a
nice throwback to the Tim Curry penny
wise design from the 1990 TV mini-series
this clown's head turns to follow
Ritchie as he walks it's good to see
something subtle like that and know that
it's not all just jump scares when they
align the map of dairying with the sewer
system map we discovered that the sewer
lines run through the 29 niebolt house
and the kids make a plan to go confront
penny wise there if you look at some of
the other locations on that map you'll
also see the cemetery which means we'll
probably see bill's confrontation with
penny wise in the sequel or penny wise
is digging graves for each of the lucky
seven the references are far from being
over there though during the beginning
of the film you may have heard bill
muttering the following phrase he
thrusts his fists against the post and
still insists he sees the ghost it comes
back again at the end of the film I
believe what this is is a coping
mechanism that bill uses to help with
his stutter and it's something that
helps them overcome penny wise in the
book because his stutter is directly
linked to his fear of it it's not that
bad at first but it gets worse when
Georgie is killed and whenever his fear
of it increases the stutter gets worse
remember when he has the courage to go
into the 29 needle house after they
discovered that it's the old well house
and it's connected to the sewer he gives
his friends a speech and Ritchie even
comments on him having not stuttered
through any of
that's his courage that allows him to
stand up like that so when you hear him
say the phrase he thrusts his fists
against the post and still insists he
sees the ghosts without stuttering you
know that he has grown in the face of
fear in order to do so and that's what
weakens it I would expect to hear more
of that phrase when his childhood
stutter comes back in Chapter two there
were a lot of little nods to events and
characters from the book that were
touched on in the movie but didn't need
to be fully expanded some of these
things had their own chapter in the book
but I think the film did a nice job of
only including what was necessary as not
to overwhelm the viewer here are a few
of those references Ben researches the
ironworks explosion a catastrophe caused
by its in the early 1900's he also looks
up the black spot fire which was a
nightclub in Derry during I want to say
the 1930s that was a hangout for a lot
of african-american men at the time it
was burned down by a racist faction with
only a few survivors one of which being
Mike Hamlin's dad who passes the story
onto his son the relevancy of that in
this movie is debatable because Mike's
parents actually do die in a fire prior
to the events of 1989 throughout the
entire movie the town is covered in
missing posters for the abducted
children many of these are references to
characters in a book whom we never meet
in the movie at least not while they're
alive
Betty rips inand Edward Corcoran are a
couple examples I found a lot of
elements from the book that were in the
movie but not really explained check
this out at one point
Pennywise encounters Richie and uses the
line beep-beep Richie which is a phrase
that the Lucky seven always uses in the
book whenever Richie doesn't shut up it
doesn't come up a whole lot in the movie
but Richie does still run his mouth a
lot the reason I wanted to bring it up
was that I feel like it kind of takes on
a new meaning here with how much of a
potty mouth Richie is in this movie the
beep-beep could represent the redacted
expletives
one other note on Richie at the school
when Richie walks by the gang of bullies
Patrick Hawks deader the one who later
goes after them with the makeshift
flamethrower gives him this creepy smile
and licks his lips
one thing this movie was very good at is
telling a lot of backstory visually
Patrick is one a messed up kid who gets
off on hurting others and has weird
violent homosexual tendencies at one
point in the book he actually molest
Henry Bowers which is why I think he's
actually the scariest human character he
doesn't get that far in the movie but
that little lick of the lips at a boy
who is substantially younger than him
tells us that something is not right
about his character there were a couple
things that were different from the book
but I think actually added to some of
the character arcs in the movie
for example while Stan is Jewish in both
the novel and motion picture his
religion plays a much bigger part now
Stan is studying for his Bar Mitzvah and
his father is the rabbi of the temple
but were given the idea that Stan isn't
really a big believer because he hasn't
been studying his Torah portion in fact
the blessing that he's having trouble
with is actually just the Prarie you
have to recite before opening the Torah
so it's like the easiest one because it
always comes up but he can't even get
through that the reason I think this is
kind of a brilliant change from the book
is that the whole basis of Stan's
character is that he's the last one to
truly believe in it he even says that
things that they're all seeing aren't
real until the niebolt
house encounter and it hits him the
hardest once he believes in it he's
probably the most scared of it and right
after that happens we're led into the
montage of the middle of that summer
where he actually has his Bar Mitzvah
his belief in it mirrors his faith in
his religion there were even a couple of
things you missed that added a touch of
Medicine in the projector scene there
are a couple of inserts of slides being
put onto the projector one says made in
Canada and one says made in USA filming
locations for this movie swapped back
and forth between these two countries
with much of dari taking place in the
Canadian City Port Hope Ontario one
thing that might have gone over your
head is the significance behind the
release date I discussed this in detail
in a previous video rolling what's more
interesting to me is why the filmmakers
have chosen the 80s for this film many
of you confirm my suspicions that the
book will be split into two movies
meaning that the second movie will take
place in 20s
sixteen the same year that part one was
in production when he considered the
fact that the first movie is technically
a flashback that kind of makes this
whole reboot series a modern-day remake
of it an interesting choice when you
consider the significance of creepy
clowns in our culture today such as the
Staten Island clowned and his many
copycats over the last few years we'll
see if that plays into the second film
at all
I'll never forget that scene in the
adult portion of the miniseries where
Ben notices Pennywise on the side of the
road something that seemed to happen
quite a lot in America in October 2016
this is our next item the film is
scheduled to release September 8th 2017
you might be wondering Assisi how did
you miss this it says it right there
well it's not the release date that I
missed but rather the significance
behind it in the story it returns to the
town every 27 years to terrorise dairy
commenter cynical cat lady points out
the first screen adaptation of it was
first aired in 1990 and 27 years later
the infamous dancing clown is
reimagining to breathe fresh terror into
a new generation just as he does in the
novel if you haven't read the book be
warned we are going in the spoiler
territory
welcome to spoiler territory in the
scene where Georgie is playing with the
boat you'll notice tents bolstered with
sandbags all around the street covering
up the sewage caps to prevent the sewer
access areas from being flooded this
plans to see it early that dairy is set
up in a way that might be prone to
flooding so don't be surprised if there
is a massive flood at the end of it
chapter 2 there are a number of subtle
references to astronomy throughout the
movie which foreshadowed the possible
inclusion of the macro verse in the
sequel the macro verse is a dark void
that surrounds our own universe
it's the place from which it and the
natural enemy of it known as the turtle
originated from the only way that
they're able to defeat it in the book
involves a ceremony known as the ritual
of should wear and stay with me here
Bill's consciousness transcends his
actual body and our universe and has a
psychic showdown with it in the macro
verse where he's given the power to
defeat it by the turtle so because of
these deep ties to the macro verse we
see countless astronomical references
scattered throughout Gary bill has a
solar system model above his desk a
rocket ship on his desk and a globe next
to his desk signifying that he could be
the one to travel to the macro verse
which we'll likely see in chapter 2 when
they're in Bill's garage Ben has a
t-shirt with many solar systems on the
dairy library shows another globe
representing earth looking very
insignificant across from a poster that
represents the scale of the greater
universe
it says reach for the stars read a book
in addition to the broader space
references there are also some
references to the turtle itself the
other thing I noticed was the Lego
turtle that bill finds in his brother's
old room which was one of the few
references to a celestial being known as
the turtle who is an opposing force
against it the turtle is kind of slyly
written into the book characters will
find themselves thinking about the
turtle without really knowing why in the
movie one of the characters brings up
the fact that they think they see a
turtle in the swimming scene and I'm not
entirely sure because again I can't
pause yet but I'm pretty sure I saw a
turtle sticker on one of Everly's books
these references are nothing more than
Easter eggs though because the primary
scene in which the turtle gives advice
to bill known as the ritual of chewed is
not a scene in this movie I wouldn't
rule it out for the sequel though the
turtles rival who the kids refer to as
it but whose true form is known as the
deadlights does make a brief appearance
when Pennywise tries to eat Beverly and
its face peels back she looks down its
throat and sees three bright lights this
is somewhat different than the form that
were used to seeing the dead lights in
they appear to be more of a force within
Pennywise as opposed to their own
powerful entity nobody in the movie
every use
the word deadlights so they make their
way onto the silver screen in a much
more subtle way this next one I didn't
notice until the last scene of the movie
in a previous things you missed I
pointed out that Beverly wears a key
around her neck and speculated what it
might be for many and I mean a lot like
a 666 billion of you pointed out that
the key is uncut so it couldn't actually
be used for unlocking anything after
seeing the movie I still have no idea
what the significance of the key is but
I noticed another piece of jewelry that
Bev has it's a ring with an anchor on it
what doing kurz do they sink and after
countless cases of you'll float - you'll
float - you'll float - the group
eventually finds that Beverly floats as
well after being abducted by Pennywise
but because of the love and dedication
of her friends they're able to find her
and pull her back down out of harm's way
in a world where all of the victims
float she's the one who sinks she's the
anchor in that final scene after the
promise and bev tells what she remembers
from when she was afloat and says she
had a vision of them when they were all
much older in their 30s this is a
foreshadowing of the sequel when after a
27-year rest
Pennywise really emerges and the losers
are called back to Derry to fulfill
their promise and vanquish it there was
also a Stephen King movie called The
Dark Tower that came out earlier in the
year and many of you speculated that
there might be some kind of Stephen King
cinematic universe in the works despite
the fact that the movies are made by
different Studios after seeing both
movies that doesn't appear to be the
case but it's still hard not to notice
some of the references to Stephen King
lore throughout the film and before I
roll this clip I'd like to mention that
this whole idea was brought about by
this teaser for The Dark Tower featuring
The Shining it carry The Shawshank
Redemption Christine and the stand let's
roll it
smith-corona is a typewriter company the
typewriter is a very important prop in
the shining I already mentioned the
Christine shirt and there's this
newspaper headline that says no
indictment yet on
USB and I wasn't able to read anything
past that but alas B as a character in
Salem's Lot in fact he's a cop by the
way this shot kinda remind anyone of
Salem's Lot after seeing the Dark Tower
I think it's also worth noting that when
Rolen describes the Mac reverse to Jake
while they're camping out in the
abandoned Pennywise amusement park thing
he draws a circle in the sand to
represent their universe and talks about
how higher beings can travel from the
outer Mac reverse into their universe
and represent this a tarantula crawls
across the sand on his diagram which of
course reminded me of the final form
this is even my final form of it or at
least the final form shown in the book
which is a giant spider so that covers
all of the things you missed from the
past videos that are still relevant now
that the movie has been released and
it's a great spot to transition into the
new things you miss that have never been
mentioned before the first of which
being an allusion to the spider that I
just brought up during the final battle
with penny wise when he's going all
ditto on the losers one of the forms he
takes looks like an arachnid at first I
thought it looked more like a praying
mantis than anything and I'll stand by
that but some of you said it reminded
you of the spider and after seeing the
miniseries again where they Bank wish
penny wisest kids and its arm turns into
a spider for just a second before
retreating deeper into the sewers I can
kind of see the resemblance
when Georgie goes into the basement to
get the wax they have a clothesline with
stuff drawing on it even though they
seemed to have a washer and dryer
already so the clothesline must be
another throwback to the miniseries
where penny wise hides behind the sheets
on the clothesline to get to Laurie Ann
also when Georgie is down in the
basement he sees a couple of lights
which he perceives his eyes but we later
find out that they just kind of
resembled the dead lights that Beverley
sees inside of penny wise when bill
builds the boat for his brother
Georgie refers to the craft as it's bill
correction telling him that he should
always call a boat she this line goes
nicely with what I brought up earlier
about Beverley being the anchor of the
group also remember belches anthrax
shirt that I brought up before I noticed
that it has
on them back as well it says follow me
or die which fits in perfectly with
belches character because he just kind
of blindly follows Henry Bowers out of
fear it's also clear that he isn't
comfortable with how Henry is cutting up
bed stomach but he won't stand up to
Henry I also have a theory that belt
does die in this movie but I'll get back
to that in a bit
some people were pointing out that the
lady from the painting creature that
stan is afraid of resembles mama from
the 2013 movie mama also directed by
Andy muschietti I wouldn't go so far as
to say that it's the same creature but I
can see a slight resemblance we see a
couple of hero shots of bill's bike
which he is named silver and in one
scene while Ben is in the library bill
and the others are riding bikes in the
street and we hear the signature phrase
hi-ho silver away which is a reference
to the Lone Ranger but more importantly
a phrase that bill imitates in the book
on several occasions when his speedy
bike riding saves the day when Ben is
researching in the library he looks at a
photo from April 3rd 1908 which is when
the ironworks explosion was and
Pennywise can be seen hiding in the
photo I don't have a still for this so
you'll have to go see for yourself we
don't find out a whole lot about
Beverly's father in this movie but he
does wear a shirt and hat that same
maintenance originally Bev's dad is the
school gender so that could explain why
he's privy in the rumors that go around
about her one of the books in bedroom is
the Frog Prince which foreshadows the
idea of a kiss being what brings her
back in the end when ben's kiss snaps
her out of her trance or whatever it was
that penny wise has done to her i caught
a few more astronomical nods to add to
the ones that i listed before in Ben's
room he has a rather large poster of
both the earth and the moon in addition
to another globe a towel on the back of
beb's door appears to have some sort of
space patterns and there's also a
picture of a flying saucer above
Georgie's bed when they first go into
the 29 niebolt house stan has a small
icon of the Sun on his shirt and while
bringing up shirts some of you wanted me
to look into Ricky's shirt that reps
Freese's department store
I guess this was a real-life store in
the actual town in Maine that helped
inspire Stephen King to write dairy
Beverley has a poster in her room for
the punk band Siouxsie and the Banshees
Beverly herself is like a front woman in
a band of all boys in the losers Club
when the kids go down into the sewer
everything and everyone that went down
the drain over the course of the film
can be found including Beverly's hair
which is seen dripping out of a pipe
after defeating Pennywise the group
shares a hug but if you look in the
background there's a light being emitted
from the drain that Pennywise retreated
into this is it retaking its true form
as the dead lights all of the abusive
parents in the town are seen watching
the same TV show which appears to be a
children's show that encourages kids to
go down into the sewers and give
themselves up to penny wise first
Eddie's mom is seen watching it and we
just get a small glimpse next we find
that his dad watching the program and
hear the line when you follow your
friends into the sewers you can be with
clowns so that's pretty disturbing but
then the show is on in front of Henry's
dad who is asleep on the couch near the
end
Pennywise appears and encourages Henry
to kill his father and then kill them
all
in a frenzy chance maybe this show is
what brainwashes the adults the reason
that they all seem so oblivious to it
the reason that his dad can't see the
blood and the reason Eddie's mom won't
look past the fact that the pills are
only gazebos
I mean placebos this show was also on a
TV when I walked through the kneeble
house Hollywood so I got to catch a
little bit more of it I will roll that
clip for you guys over here
[Music]
[Music]
if you want to see that whole
walkthrough I'll leave a link to my
video in the card right here
incidentally I think that Henry does end
up killing them all or at least he tries
when he shows up to ambush the losers at
the 29 meatball house just before the
film's end he rolls up in belches car
the TransAm with considerably more blood
on his face than when we last saw him
when he killed his dad
it looks like belch might be a goner and
possibly also Victor will see if there
ends up being any deleted scenes when
the blu-ray comes out moving on the
mural next to the meat place that Mike
works at is constantly changing
it starts off innocent enough then after
the kids steal from the drug store I
noticed it depicting something called
the brutal battle which features a dead
person then at some point
Pennywise ends up in the mural artwork
as well perhaps the biggest thing that
I'm looking forward to in the sequel is
the possible inclusion of the flood that
overruns Derry as a reminder this
happens after the standpipe explodes
when the remainder of the losers Club
defeat it as adults I didn't catch this
the first time around because I always
imagined the standpipe to be an actual
pipe that ruptures but as it turns out
it's actually a full-on building and
there are a lot of references to it upon
first meeting Ben he's carrying a school
project which is a model of the
standpipe he ends up dropping it causing
it to pop off the ground just like it
presumably will in the next move
the postcard that he buys for Beverly to
write the poem on contains a picture of
the standpipe
when he first exits the library he cuts
through Memorial Park where the
standpipe is supposed to be located it's
also somewhat near Beverly's apartment a
shot of the standpipe
ends up being used as transition before
scene taking place at her home and
finally I think the final battle was
penalized at the end of the movie is
supposed to be located inside the
standpipe when they looked up at the
giant Tower of floating kids the shape
of the structure that they're in looks
similar to the shape of the outside of
the standpipe and if it's going to burst
it would make sense that the pressure is
building up from underneath it and last
but maybe most importantly of all
Ritchie's t-shirt in the final scene is
a bike in cycle shop graphic tee aside
from that being the store where bill
originally buys his bike silver from the
book I was able to make one other
connection the only other cycling shirt
I noticed in the movie was Georgie's in
the very first opening scene before he
even puts on the raincoat maybe the
words cycle takes on a second meaning
here Derry is constantly stuck in a
cycle of Pennywise re-emerging every 27
years and this time the cycle begins
with the murder of Georgie and
effectively ends when Richie has the
bravery to stand up and attack anyways
but like all cycles the events that make
it up the spokes of this metaphorical
wheel will come around again in chapter
2 I know this video was a little on the
long side hopefully you found it to be a
long game but a goodie just like my last
episode of all day and a creepypasta
which you can check out right here or if
you're interested in more things you
missed have a look at this playlist so
remember to subscribe to seize these
worlds for new Horrors every week ring
that death bell for notifications and
I'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive